actor Danny Masterson is facing decades
in prison after a Los Angeles jury found
him guilty of two counts of rape
Masterson was accused of sexually
assaulting three women in the early
2000s this was while he was starring on
That 70s Show Lise Preston shows us that
the Church of Scientology was also a big
issue at trial
actor Danny Masterson was escorted out
of a Los Angeles courtroom in handcuffs
Wednesday guilty on two counts of rape
jurors were deadlocked on a third rape
charge
after a hung jury led to a mistrial last
year prosecutors tried Masterson again
accusing the actor of drugging and
raping the three women at his Hollywood
Hills home from 2001 to 2003. Mrs
Foreman that's the same time he was
starring in a sitcom That 70s Show the
Church of Scientology played a central
role in the trial like Masterson the
three women were members they testified
that they reported Masterson to
Scientology officials but because of his
prominence at the church we're told they
were not raped feared excommunication
and discouraged from going to the police
the church strongly denies blocking the
victims or anyone from cooperating with
authorities CBS News legal contributor
Jessica Levinson I think the jury
believed that they believed the
narrative that the Church of Scientology
and its members would have retaliated
against them if they had reported this
and that's why they waited and that's
why they interacted with Danny Masterson
in different ways and continue to
interact with him the Church of
Scientology did not respond to our
requests for comment Masterson who also
did not respond to CBS has long denied
any wrongdoing but did not testify and
his lawyers didn't call any Witnesses
for CBS mornings I'm Elise Preston in
Los Angeles